hoy se han empezado a relajar al fin el
estricto encierro podrán salir de casa
aquellos que vivan en áreas donde no se
ha detectado ni un solo positivo en las
dos últimas semanas la medida no
responde a una mejoría de la situación
de hecho se ha informado de más de
25.000 nuevos casos lo que supone un
nuevo récord por décimo día consecutivo
pero las autoridades han atendido al
hastío generalizado y sobre todo a las
quejas por el suministro de alimentos
muchos shanghaineses culpan a sus
autoridades de falta de diligencia en
las fases iniciales del brote de haber
confiado en confinamientos localizados
que se demostraron inútiles y que
obligaron al cierre total de la ciudad
cuando los casos ya estaban desatados
esas enseñanzas de shanghai sirven ahora
para todo el país en guangzhou la macro
ciudad del sur y capital de la provincia
de cantón han bastado una veintena de
casos entre sus 15 millones de
habitantes para que se cerraran las
escuelas de inmediato y se ordenarán
test masivos